hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
now I am a little late today sorry I had
some business to take care of this
morning but now we are getting back into
it and we just destroyed both pieces of
Stefano's art quote-unquote art lots of
quotes lots of unquote s' we have no
idea what's going on there bye we have
more to do I know there's a lot of
things outside that we need to take care
of is there anything else that you know
no no no I don't need anything from you
so we got to get out there and we got no
time to waste because we're gonna get
right into the thick of it we're gonna
go straight to the theater unless we
need to find something else is there any
other like notable or noteworthy thing
over here I don't think so
there was all the other materials that
were over here but then I ran away like
a screaming baby boom so maybe I should
go back to that but I do have a lot of
ammo right now
Oh I wonder if I should worry dude well
that's that son of a [ __ ] is just a big
giant
I mean there are more gas canisters all
throughout the is getting brighter what
the Sun's up
oh no that's a lamp sorry but the Sun
was a lamp everybody calmed down I
thought the Sun was a lamp right but the
main issue is we don't think there's
anything like super pressingly urgent
over there so we're gonna go right for
you know what I'm gonna go right for it
we're gonna go for it oh wait no there's
a lotta sue there I'm a big brave boy
I'm gonna run through it anyway oh okay
well that was squishy Boosh I never
thought the bush would betray me like
that alright fine I'll go around ever
need you it's a big lady over there
laughing ladies over there and I think
we're OK clear shot straight to where we
need to go let's do this
that wasn't anything else that we needed
right there's no other signals there's
no other nothing okay I'm pretty sure
we're good at least I'm good anyway
again I said I wasn't gonna do an
absolute completion there out of this I
was just gonna go everything that was
readily plain in front of my eyes but
now that we got this and the way is
clear to us hi hello what a bright shiny
day it is oh hello neighbor
alright see ya hello neighbor my
absolute favorite game that hasn't been
getting worse every update no no it's
wonderful
alright gross yeah go on brush your
shoulder hi hello how's it going are you
doing I like what you've done with the
place
all the bodies and such oh did I say
like I'm in hate I'm in absolutely hate
with every fiber of my being
[Music]
for sama been this close to the groans
white fog that doesn't seem good huh but
given the choices and movies here I
think I'd rather think it rather good
rather see do what's going on with the
white fog hello he's gotta be here
somewhere
there's one thing I found there's one
thing I'm good
destroy my work yeah you expect me to
bend to your will kind of yes like them
thinking they could stopped me into what
I am not what they created in here it's
marvelous
they wasted it because they had no
imagination huh because they are not
artists they want to control me
manipulate me you want to stop me well
you have failed because with the power
of the core I can create my art forever
okay all right so you don't want to be
molded into something that you're not
kind of like what you're doing with all
the bodies is it kind of like that you
know how you take people against their
will and mold them into what you think
they should be is that what you don't
want to happen to you Oh cruel irony I
can't believe it can I use this the
reason Azir can I just let go around
town can I be that zombie that just
pushes around a popcorn cart oh I'm a
seven - popcorn machine all right well
where are you show your face and I'll
show you exactly what I mean to do to
you
I'll sculpt you a few new bullet holes
I remember that music everything's roped
off ok Revere alright they might know
they might know because this is or
actually you know what Mobius won't let
anybody know oh all right
I thought I thought those might have
been key statues maybe they still are
let me go good ol whomping I've
forgotten entirely warm ok no no the
boob statues aren't exactly what I was
going for all right then I guess it's
off to the races we go
I wonder what's gonna be lurking behind
this door maybe a boss fight maybe it's
gonna be a boss fight with Stefano
Valentino no I'll gamble that one ok and
full of something else too but oh well
hey yaa wooo cutscene first-person
perspective cutscene that's weird look
it's Oh though I don't like that
no don't like that at all the hell is he
doing to these people
how many people were in there snow
[Music]
hello this has been entertaining but
even the greatest entertainments must
come to an end
uh-huh the girl where is she I commend
you for making it this far
if perseverance were an art form law
would be a master yeah Oh perhaps not
Michelangelo but a van God enough art
school [ __ ] where is she
the core is safe with me
I took her on his orders lose his wish
his you're his or mine realize the
extent of our powers mmm what I'm doing
is more important than mere personal
gain he could never understand this he
who is he
that's what I want to know it doesn't
matter no I think he won't be around
much longer
ah wait a minute work however will
continue okay all right what are we oh
that's oh no I don't know no no oh no oh
come on
Picasso had his blue have entered my
crimson period no don't
we're home my latest creation
No
[Music]
I'm gonna stab the [ __ ] out of you I'm
going to stab not you Alice Tufano I am
going to stab the [ __ ] out of you I
don't care how many stabs it's gonna
take I'm gonna stab the ever living [ __ ]
out of you just like I need to your
paintings almost damage it out of you
sick bastard you can't find a way no no
I might as well
nd here's always smile okay okay yeah
I'm gonna stab this [ __ ] out of you
looks like someone needs a soup delivery
standing hey whoa hey hang on it hang on
a second yeah oh yeah I'm coming through
this hole here we go graze bud stabber
incoming
climbed down okay a boaster oh my ass
yeah all right
yeah it's my sack intact okay good
I feel like all this is just rotting
into my brain right now and I don't
actually have any control over
everything
the more they exploded the environment
that's pieces of my brain they're
they're like shattering away but the
question is like how real how real is
any of that death like I really do
relative like is that death entirely
real because this is oh oh I'm dead what
what what oh I did I didn't realize that
I was playing the cover gang here
okay all right you don't see nothing
apparently ah I see what's going on if I
get detected I'm I'm dead I'm dead
yeah iê iê iê haha nailed that one
there ain't no way you're gonna detect
some of this Oh soup ain't gonna be
stopped today soup is on the menu take
that yes please can I shoot you in your
big dumb eye that's something I can do
exact lad Lee shoot you and your big
dumb eye is that like his eye that's
been implanted with a camera for some
reason so he can always immortalize the
memories that which he sees which is
awful but there's a thing the fairly oh
come on how is that not skidooed Lee
under oh now I gotta wait here like an
[ __ ] cuz you made me do it
piece of [ __ ] I move
my bad my bad max max max
Aleut I'm going for it
that moves keep going okay there we go
starting to get a hang of this holiness
but I'm pretending I'm a badass okay all
right where the [ __ ] did you go yeah
time for a soup oh do you want to get
the whole menu
I got a four-course meal planned for you
you get soup and salad thank you very
much
wait why do it why's why why do I have a
mirror here but why do I have this looks
like they're loading me up okay all
right okay all right I see what's going
on here
tell me out
hello meow meow what's going on yeah
okay alright see ya I gotta grab me up
some bullets and then see what's going
on with the nurse lady see if she has
any advice about this because there's
something suspicious oh I just don't
have enough not quite enough let me see
if I can craft up some bullets hey I'm
actually doing pretty good let me get
some [ __ ] shells
I've even got sniper rifle bullets and
that's really good alright make me
smoothi-- should have made more harpoons
with the Gunpowder but the last shotgun
shells are just as good once I get close
to him far away I don't think I'm gonna
be able to shotgun that giant camera in
the sky but you know I'm gonna try my
best yeah I need some advice there's a
giant eyeball in the sky and I don't
know what to do about it
just taking a breather to face one of
your greatest challenges will you be
ready for it
no your help I hope so oh oh maybe there
are others here who can assist you you
have the same goal you haven't met them
yet if they even exist and there's no
time to wait for them I hope you're
ready you are still so full of rage
uncertainty maybe but Lily needs me I
have to at least try and if you die
trying
dying isn't an option for me yeah sure
let's go with that one let's go with
that do I have any do I've a anything
like an one locker key
Oh magical lockers what secrets do you
hold this one gah
oh yeah oh I'm a van Gogh alright
alright let's see what I can put in my
brain there's nothing wrong with being
cautious wait no nothing that's not what
I wanted
how about just a health up can I get a
health up that's always good alright if
an attack would have just barely done
enough damage to kill you you'll grit
your teeth and bear it remaining alive
with a small amount of hay that's that's
not bad I like I like the sound of that
that's that's not bad you're at raise
your pain threshold allowing you to
survive attacks you should that should
have done more than enough damage to
kill you alright okay so it's like it's
like defiance this is like I choose not
to die it's like you're in a LARP
session so with like magic missle you're
like no uh-uh
no that didn't work on me so when I go
up to that giant camera in the sky that
slams a tentacle into my butt I just go
no no oh no no no that didn't work on me
no no not tentacle today sir or ma'am or
whatever you are and then everything
will be hunky-dory and I'll be super
happy right that's how it works
no probably outwards maybe alright let's
see let's make just three more of these
make some explodey boats how those ski I
used too many of those
I don't think smoke bombs are gonna work
on the giant eye in the sky but you know
it is ah we could make more handgun
bullets because I always liked that BAM
oh the sacs almost full Oh Pappy would
be so proud of me
okay I'm gonna save then we're gonna get
into this about my combat what combat
what combat I have a restaurant or serve
I'm gonna show him the menu I'm not
gonna do anything
deviously dastardly to this person I
don't do combat I new enhance soup
skills that's all I got excuse me I
didn't know if this was the door I was
supposed to be going through houses and
checking you know okay that was Daoist
indeed the door I was supposed to go
through okay just wanted to be certain
just wanted to be sir all right hello
hello ah this is definitely the resident
evil house all right oh the sneaking
chair thus pooping chair I forgot about
that
oh man Stefano you really could have
taken an opportunity because I totally
forgot about the spooking chair so long
if you guys don't see you could have
been oh you could have me come up the
stairs and you could have been in this
spooking chair and when I came around
the corner you could have gone oh boo
shoot you shoot I'm not gonna waste
bullets to accentuate my point there but
you get what I'm saying hey oh come on
God more spooky oh I see the spook and
chair at the end of the hallway that
would have been a great surprise
man oh okay oh so startled by you I'll
see this guy's got the right idea about
the spooking chair oh it was very spooky
oh that's not good I don't like that
whoa oh my god I was so startled all
right man a lot of scariness happening
over here I've never used my med kit not
once probably cuz it takes so much
damage I'll just die in two days good
maybe I should be running that whole
save my daughter kind of thing oh yeah
after [ __ ]
okay sorry Sebastian freaked out for a
second there
okay so much okay
all right I've got a lot of soup you
want that let me sneak in here okay
maybe he doesn't know I'm on the way
maybe I can get the jump on him all
right Sebastian Castellanos say okay all
right then let me sneak on hang on wait
wait for it wait here comes the soup oh
oh I'm standing now apparently no more
running no more games no more game
agreed you're beginning
[Music]
okay whatever you say man what is time
what is I gotta change it to the loud
soup deliver way no hey what was I doing
there we go you're on it what you cannot
oh I can see you very clearly I'm gonna
go hide now
excuse me time to soup it up if I can
soup this guy good boy
oh I can avoid you alright you don't you
don't know wow oh okay all right you got
a soup you got a you you got long range
soup okay all right ohyeah okay wait no
[Music]
oh miss me ha ha
it's gonna be soup on soup a ha ha I'm
ready for this Dan oh I don't know you
there you seem to be there oh ok your
soups soups pretty robust
I gotta admit that minestrone
oh well this ain't good Ross no little
grin and bear I'm gonna grin and bear it
oh part yes I grinned and I bared it oh
I'm so tough you're ready for soup and
weight all right okay so soup on soup
action ain't gonna do everybody get out
your ladle that would be my newest piece
of Myrtle just be ladies all right and
wait shut up for a second wait what what
all I run out of am I now okay all right
well then you know sucks to be you okay
I should duck when that happens Frosch
duck and how did this oh yeah that's
right cuz it's just hang on I gotta
change that to two there we go
I'm gonna put the way did some
micromanagement here I'm gonna put this
does have him all right there we go I
can get both
I don't know about that one
I'm gonna regret a lot of things that
I'm doing to you shortly oh he's
smarming miss me miss miss you too sure
okay no it's so funny to me oh okay all
right then well let's go with this one
okay
all right Ben mr. Chloe I can I suit you
now
hey no we said no tentacles in the air
oh come on
that's hardly fair all right
that's a lot of stab I don't like that
well I mean there's clearly essential
whoa I ducked I'm gonna grin and bear
that but first I'm gonna I'm gonna chat
you up good let me just shoot up some
drugs here we go what's this oh that
looks pretty come on see what this is
all about
wow that was a bomb whose bomb guys I
found out what it was it was a bomb okay
that's a knife to the heart that's a
knife he's pretty quick guys he's pretty
quick guy made this guy scream pretty
quick
William oh I missed him come on yeah
yeah baby yeah time for Sue befo going
mi know know if I am
Oh
no I don't wanna I'd rather not that's a
personal preference okay I'm gonna
really grin and bear that one hey you
gonna just stand there okay no okay all
right well let me just shoot up here
Oh ah that feels good I'm pretty grin
and bear able to show you know
I don't like this no thank you miss me
dick bag get you
think you're gonna get me
No are you
thank you what a good host you are
are you running uh it's kind of a sense
in it
okay I don't want to hide
no okay all right let's get this guy
don't know what he's doing about man
all right we're ready come on woodwork I
want to slap you with my soup
duck no no I don't want your blood I
don't wanna like I said before are you
sweating get away from that one he just
sprints for you that's no good oh my I'm
trying my best guys I'm trying my best
use the bombs okay
how how though but he'll though okay
okay the bombs you said
yeah
no sexy Nawrocki come on good doc
nothing adduct enough is what is okay
ah that got blue that blue me
Wow okay so don't use the box like that
okay wow that was close okay so I think
I gotta like
I don't know man I don't know I can't
really shoot the balls
not that okay
shoot the bucket but you can't shoot the
box ton work okay
good touch it don't work he can run into
the bomb okay that's that was my
original assess number dot here real
quick reset my help okay
so just move and shoot you fool shoot
the bombs that you can't shoot the box
what did I just say yeah yeah I'm
thinking you you have to use the bombs
of the trap otherwise it's just a shoot
and move kind of deal but the only
problem is when he when he does his like
little sprint move when he does his
sprint maneuver he like he comes
straight for you so quickly and then he
just grabs you so he watch
yep there there that maneuver
so there's something that like does
something else to it it's gotta me
because if he runs like that and even if
you get nearer ya get near them they
blow like that so all these got it is
getting near them yeah I'm just dying
because I'm trying to get this get this
underway mmm babies damn covers up don't
worry inside count this wall there's the
trust you mean tell us is low oh wow
okay well that was a mistake
kick the bucket real quick super didn't
grin and bear that okay no I think it's
just gonna be heal up as much as you can
and he's if he comes and stabs you which
is very likely action count I don't want
to play it so close to the chest that uh
that uh every little thumb is gonna
thank you
come on really really really Sebastian
you're gonna do the ballet spin
pirouette right when I need you the most
yes stupid dick wait I think it's if I
destroy his heart he comes near by
no [ __ ] you were aiming for my grundle
there that's no good oh wait he just did
the philistine thing but he didn't go
for it but he didn't he didn't help
there he goes that's a nice the
Philippine thing yeah I think it's when
I try to shoot his bombs what all I
grinned and better cuz you like sprinted
for me see he can't set off cuz he's
standing right next to it it's not
blowing up but oh you can ah but it
didn't do anything did it couldn't tell
okay all right amazing I'm gonna just do
this straight-up modeling on a sound
they use all like the other items on
this next run-through you're so sweet
there's a lot of sense in running taking
a picture
narak Oh God Wow miss me
ah so it's just off running of the balls
as you would know yeah ow God stop
inning for my grundle if that's very
unfair I wonder
I can only really get one Wow okay damn
it okay I got it did you forget okay so
I just kind of stay running stay mobile
pretty much I think that's the only
really law of the land no I don't want
okay yeah okay
right how scary I'm gonna switch to
shooty Gunny come on
and I really shouldn't waste two bullets
on that one wait
throw a knife these are all like little
plans and plots my throat blow it up
what Danny didn't blood
huh
you okay watch shot
wait that's close
no god dammit I wasn't I was running I
shoulda just run forward jus just gone
forward okay let me just pound I'm gonna
get up I'm gonna do a fully wooly Medi
weddy kid on that one they put that bad
boy in my blood there we go all of this
that's not over but it is what it is
keep throwing your stupid little knife
ain't nothing to my soup I don't want to
did you think I was gonna work yeah
don't tell him that
full of convenient Oh perfect
I love me a mo oh that was my bad though
stupid me okay on my heel up stupid of
me
oh yeah shoot that write it shoot that
all and good thing I got a lot of x' hey
wait hey shut up for a second I got a
field just shut your shut your goddamn
face here shut your goddamn face hey
wait isn't that the same amount of cost
oh that's lovely
Oh perfect oh that's like nothing Oh
easy peasy oh I got this in the bag
okay sure whatever you say
I'll come closer come closer please come
little closer there's a lot of sense
oh my artist oh wow products cheap oh
nothing the gut my precious gun I like
that gun damn you
I can try
he's doing the walkie
whoa Running of the Bulls all right I
can do this dance I can do this dance
mr. Dancy fancy pants there we go whoa
he triggers those ones but I don't know
if they hurt him I don't think those
actually hurt him
appreciate that but I'm gonna try Shogun
next take a selfie come on perfect
opportunity for the best hard I would
have been remembered forever by hooking
bedtime for a big giant I okay I had so
much left to create you know what you
want some soup
destroyed my legacy like chicken lentil
you made me into a masterpiece must
record it hey Sophie where did it go
I don't feel even a little bit bad the
only thing I feel bad about is that I
didn't get to stab you
okay so who's him who guesses Rubik on
the other side of this door oh come on
selfie please take a cell phone please
selfie
Oh Lily don't be afraid honey it's me
dad no no you're not
oh come on honey I know that what they
told you but it's not true
Lily please I come out Lily you don't
have to hide oh oh oh it's my worst fear
oh it's my worst fear it's my worst fear
goopy goopy I will protect you
mara get away you can't have her
[Music]
really hard
why why are you so goopy Myra oh I'm at
my desk okay all right then well great
great great Myra Myra Boober see my wife
Myra okay I'll be out here for you and
someone else will be in there for you
Kidman she knew about Myra
mmm-hmm not good they're not good [ __ ]
you know Sebastian you ain't looking too
good these days maybe you should take a
little nap okay so how many of these
people have we found oh hello well
that's that's not good a giant red X now
that's art not on these people though
okay so these three people are alive but
these are dead oh I guess nothing else
to say about that all right well that
answers one question but I don't think
we're at the end oh that's new yeah
that's you guys haven't what's you guys
haven't seen that before right that that
wasn't there
Oh interesting
my projectors become paws Oh what is
this watch the mirror
yeah where's the mirror huh okay all
right I'll play your game oh it's those
fiery guys it's the fire circle people
oh where is this place it's your office
Sebastian you kind of took a turn for
depravity at some point in your life
maybe when you lost all of your family
might by oh I thought that was my soup
deliver oh it's so ready for soup all
right fine then Jays jay-z Christmas
west mess oh thank you for that I do
need to restock after the last endeavor
I'm glad I was able to finish that with
mostly pistol because that saved me a
lot of ammo cuz they kept giving it to
me I mean who do they think I am I'm
kind of bad no way all right oh I
thought that was a statue this does seem
like this kind of place where there
would be a statue with maybe a can it
boil foil but I'll miss that people
aren't gonna forgive me if I do that uh
you you got a key are you know
like that okay that's weird got key in
here key everybody see the key bug yeah
hi and a tiny tiny lady statue
anybody know all right I'm out of here
all right see you see you next week Oh
Sebastian Castellanos got food whoa
thank you deep voice man I don't know
why don't you go find out mm-hmm that's
slanty boxers all right thank you got me
some smelling salts some smelling flower
whew bullets thank you
they're loading me up you would one
would think that this is either post
boss load up or actually something bad
happening load up and I'm not sure which
I like less all right is that a way out
or is that a way trap okay that's a way
trap okay I don't like this you guys
keep your heads on a swivel if you see
anything you let me know let me know
about that I was there telling you to
keep your head on a swivel and you did
nothing could have died gonna burn me up
oh that's just an Iron Maiden
man I'm getting a lot of amnesia the
Dark Descent vibes being of which should
be good oMG were burned alive
oh just burned all these torture
equipment that that did nothing yeah
yeah just burned okay all right yeah
sure
torture devices
this place is almost medieval this guy
was only burned alive
this guy was only tortured detective
Castellanos has solved the mystery
everybody go home we're all done here
thank you for the warning I saw someone
say watch out I appreciate that
not quite as timely as I would have
hoped for but I'm gonna go through that
door I saw over there hopefully that's
got some more answers for me maybe a
little less death Who am I kiddin and
you know what's weird things like cuz
this all is taking place in if that is
Lily which maybe it is maybe it's not
thinking it's not thinking a lot of not
why it is Lily then this is all taking
place in her mind that means these
things are like in her brain that's
that's not good
oh I this is not good speaking of not
good crawling into a an underbrush of
death and blood is definitely not good
yeah I was wondering about that I was
wondering if the photography guy was
gonna be like the final boss but he is
reporting to something else so there's
like some greater greater evil at play
here that's not the boss outside sitting
on his big old throne what you would
think it would be is when you ever you
see a big boss on a big throne you think
all that guys in charge any day probably
give him some soup he looks a little
sick lay down the bed let me feed you
some soup all right carrying on I think
I don't even know if what I got was all
that important but I got it nonetheless
hello oh Crawley call alright yeah sure
okay Go Go this oh nothing bad gonna
happen down here no I know how Oh
brain soup ooh hey a friend you you
thought you could sneak on me no way I'm
the only one that sneaks notes on people
here
mm-hmm that's warm warm brain soup ah
good yes anything in here a bose game no
okay all right thank you good goodbye
farewell nice candle al my balls
it's got calmly walk over this candle
please who's al okay all right then all
right let's see what we got over here
also like what happened with Myra I mean
I know that Myra was like looking for a
family but in the end of the last game
wasn't Myra like part of Mobius didn't
Myra somehow join them or something boom
cuz if that's the case then that's super
weird right
but now she's in here why would she be
in here and why would she be totally
cool with and wait so Stefano said to
him he requested Lily which I'd still
don't think is Lily all right
something something don't add up here
something don't add up here yeah Oh
amnesia oh I want to play more custom
stories and stuff not that there have
been many new custom stories and amnesia
lately but you know that was always fun
and I think there are a bomb there are
some custom stories for soma that could
be super fun
well oh I see you over there you see
that guy doing the freaky dance over
there no wait no I didn't want that I
wanted to wait for coffee hang on I
meant this where you go you see what I'm
seeing right wait yeah I'm not gonna
waste a bullet on you but hey who you
keep dancin you gave damage until the
end of your days you haven't good he's
having a good time definitely good Who
am I to stop that
all right little get here anyone in need
of some soup oh yeah I forgot it's seven
I got to change this to like eight so I
don't hit it accidentally and this this
does six there we go that'll do
hello oh is that a key statue I think
that's key statute I gotta figure out a
way to open these up because I gotta get
in there excuse me
Wampus you didn't hear nothing did you
okay you're too busy praying I think
weird all right so there's got to be a
mechanism by which to unlock these doors
right I see gears and I see chains
maybe something up above this I'll just
have to keep an eye out for it hopefully
when I get to it oh this is it this is
it this thing wen Kuang can't turn it no
I use your strong arms you got big burly
arms oh yeah I figured that one huh I
got a bottle in my hand okay yes that's
the opposite of good
okay snakes nonk you didn't hear
where'd he go Oh slowpoke over there who
where'd he go where'd he go
no no oh let's see
today's all-you-can-eat mozzarella
sticks so that's kind of nice point okay
just one take my time on that one all
right
all right so anybody else wake up
can I get a crank handle were you
supposed to wake up there can I spin
stomp on okey yep that was okay whoa he
had a bad dream wha okay
all right come on what are you doing all
right
I think the rear nope
let me press my palms gently up against
that here no how do you open all these
doors I have a funny feeling maybe if I
ask Dancy pants over here they're gonna
be able to tell me what's going on
uh-huh uh-huh oh do tell yeah okay I'm
with it I'm hip sir Sir please please
reason with me please just reason ah oh
I can't give you the bars are too thick
to deliver soup behind I'm sorry it's
the way life is
came through here a palm okay
so far so good Oh handle Cranky's can I
just crack oh yeah that's gonna unleash
everything yeah that's what I was
looking for that's what I was hoping for
all right now I can shoot these guys up
good okay
uh-oh see ya got places to be
Dancy pants just ran off as fast as he
could alright as hilarious alright you
don't see a thing
you can't possib what no I don't know
what that was you are you kidding me are
you even joking Josh oh sorry
[Music]
okay so I imagine that there's a lot of
these [ __ ]
lerton around here anybody Oh Dancy
pants hat Oh Dancy pants had the goods
oh we had the goods
oh we had all the goods oh hell yeah
this is up an answer for me okay
everybody be quiet be quiet keep your
ears listening oh yeah you're yeah that
no I was thinking I was thinking that
and I see that I kind of connect the
dots there now where are you gonna go
buddy
oh hello okay dancing pants no no no no
need for anything cuz that guy gotta get
out of the cage or why my wakey wakey
eggs and Bakey I got places to be
oh come on what are you doing
why why why would you do that what why
exactly that okay you know what how
about you just do this oh well that was
weird
turn around dancer pants you don't need
to see this no turn around come on
[ __ ] wasting all of our times there
we go oh you're gonna sprint back into
place
almost no no no no no yeah there we go
this soup right to yourself why who did
that what and how oh hello a ye okay
well excuse me Jimmy you didn't what did
you see something I don't know what you
think you saw but it was a al I told you
by the government and I love my sneaking
skills for the best daddy
I think that was dancing pants I'm
pretty sure that was Dancy pants which
is a damn shame because frankly that was
my favorite one
all right we got here
no nothing all right
okay I know there's more of you know
there's a lot more of you Oh
okay that's gonna be a bit of a hey
welcome to the party
it's not gonna be that much of a problem
because I know exactly how to take care
of you I know how to treat a keep
planting over there don't don't
appreciate it no no you wanna fall not a
cup I got it
okay I get it oh that's one Oh not ideal
okay you know what I'm actually going
okay
shame my my plans been foiled oh yeah
okay still don't know they still don't
know oh wait maybe they I think they
know okay they know maybe this guy knows
we'll see we'll see what happens when I
do a little bit of this to bring your
gob did you think what did you see what
you you think you saw something whoops
whoopsies whoopsies whoops you bring
around the rosey
my steps are so subtle oh that that's
that's not what I wanted a year okay oh
that's that's probably bad all right you
didn't see nothing lady
oh yeah you keep raging against those
bars those chains are so confusing over
there all right go back come from okay
all right okay all right yeah sure okay
all right let's going back [ __ ] spits
I think I think sprinty lady is right
behind me I think's pretty late
literally right by me okay did she oh no
she didn't turn around okay she's good
we're good we're all good
got hot hot soup coming your way all
right hang on
where she go did she sprint back that's
a nice bring it back
yeah she's bring it back okay all right
then good thing I'm so and stealthy
uh-huh yeah huh would tell me more
oh yes oh yes but what are you doing
no no it's one eye I don't know which
one I want to have mercy on first there
you go good that guy huh something done
something's going on in that brain not
the right thing than the wrong thing all
right
winner winner super dinner okay Oh oh
sorry okay well you dropped your knife
I'll take it let's just inject this
knife slurp the soup out of that one
leftover stuff on the blades edge sorry
not sorry at all all right well that was
successful didn't take a lick of damage
now what's in here actually
okay all right okay yes yes my arrow sac
finally I've been hoping all right it is
a natural human desire to resist whether
its resisting change resisting Authority
or resisting desire but the mental and
emotional toll of such resistance often
outweighs the benefits gained by it the
universe is too well organized to
perfect in its construction how could we
possibly believe that such perfection
arose from chaos is my hypothesis that
there is a plan for me for you for each
and every one of us some people say that
everything happens for a reason some
people call it fate whatever it is woe
unto those who attempt to resist it
there's no reason to resist ever don't
do it don't you dare look around at your
cells and be grateful for what you have
I think that's what the the core of the
message is there is there one hungry
patient left well I hear that writer is
that just goofs is it the praying guy
nice bottle in your face grabby ants
yeah you didn't expect that did you huh
oh yeah no yeah you were surprised
shocked even now let me feel this wall
pretty good no I want to look I feel
like they can see me
okay I'm coming for it come on little
closer little closer
Oh cousin what's come on ah you know you
know closer come on man come on mom
please
Oh No
no no whoa oh wait whoa hey don't get
frisky all right
whoo yeah you got that all under way all
right let's get this ski
oh we're gonna jet out here point all
right got it got it got it we're out of
here
I think that might have been hey hey
wake up rude rude rude I can't believe
you yeah oh oh here he comes
all right here comes here comes here
comes before no no I'll never get there
it was my favorite thing all right okay
I could have stopped him I don't think I
could uh I've tried that before it don't
work too well for me and for them
there's no one's happy at the end of
that day all right everybody's dead now
I've got so much brain goop that's
perfect actually
oh oh
yeesh in as hard as I can Yosh okay
there we go we got it wait
hmm what a map in there
I don't but alright okay well that's
weird I didn't even know that there was
frequencies down here huh
alrighty then good for me I guess now
what else we got here
I'm Foskey Sebastian Castellanos mom hey
that oh sorry didn't notice you there
Oh gross okay ah Sebastian Castellanos
somebody call let it ring hmm okay
alright then what's the point of these
where there are so many jail cells get
another one
oh that's a mobius operative oh geez
alrighty then the union a ye okay
alright well that's that's sad
okay alright
not good Oh boxes that's a little ray of
sunshine in this dark and dreary abode
no one thought to break these oh yeah
are they hiding a secret perfect I love
it when boxes hide things Oh perfect Oh
excellent where's the tiny box Tim when
you need them oh hello you got the
shotgun shells why are you so
ritualistic Ali lit up I don't like that
I don't like that at all mmm okay all
right then what have you got sir why are
Mobius operatives in here oh sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry I didn't mean it so I
had to think about that for a second
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry hello oh I'm
sorry I just I can't leave anybody go
hungry you know what I mean would you
like a nice ahi tartare you think he
sees me
okay I think he's he's a mite bit
suspicious I don't know if I can throw
this thing correctly it unsay me wait
wait there's a sprint oh god it was our
guy I would love to have Sammy sprint
out of this tunnel and completely break
the game turn around
come on now Oh your hand is so goopy and
I don't like that Oh get out of here I
guess yeah okay sorry
let me put you out of your misery I
don't know how that's happening to
Mobius operators I didn't even know that
Mobius operatives could become zombies
like that I thought they all dad the
chip in their brain they would like keep
them grounded or whatever but something
tells me that the rules are starting to
break around here and things ain't apply
in the same way that they should habu
skate Sebastien hustle I fail to see the
logic of that mr. preacher from outlast
- I don't want that at all
no I've never seen Mobius go why didn't
you warn me about that I was reading for
a second I'd got distracted okay well I
guess I can't go back up that's one way
of doing that yeah I didn't think the
möbius möbius in a Mobius zombie before
okay all right okay then what are you
gonna help me hello
wait let me get a good look at ya let me
get a really good look at you okay you
either got a lot of beard going on some
kind of shawl or those are tentacles and
I I'm probably gonna shoot you I'll
probably shoot you nonetheless but you
know mmm
thumpy thump
okay
oh yeah who are you what do you want
with me ooh
[Music]
super cool Oh
I don't know what's going on but I love
it I'm trying I'm trying to well II oh
wow ah that hurts and burns oh that's
that's a problem okay that's that's not
good oh yeah no good I don't like that
yeah that hurts
Oh oh you're real oh whoa wait whoa whoa
bougie spooky spooky yeah okay I I am
not prepared for this
I'm not prepared for this oh boy oh boy
don't hug me please don't hug me I don't
want that
ie I some tells me soup ain't gonna work
on you guys I'm gonna just wrap my thumb
third fret my sweet boy ladle are you
okay yeah yo any of you and I don't like
any of you even less okay all right
there you go
well that's partial partial soup
implantation you guys looks like you
already got some hot hot soup in yes Oh
first though they were all doing a
football charge all right Wow okay
you're a little tougher than I imagined
Oh hit the other one mind you don't know
how I'd ask that okay there we go
kiba's Phoebus yeah bus you all right
thank you for that thank you
thank you Oh soup works on them oh okay
all right I'll try my best
next time I just do three of them than
them all seeing me I just kind of like
blind to be sure about that way stalling
shotgun ammo hope you guys don't mind
that all right anyway did he use my pun
keep forgetting do you use my poon
that's full but I do need to take that
that is probably one of those oh that's
good good okay this last one man they
don't even give that much brain soup all
right fine next time I'm gonna not spend
a lot of time and effort on what are you
God Stefano
okay all right
yeah so uh kind of credit should I give
for that that's that doesn't seem good
doesn't seem like a good thing because
if this guy's able to break the rules to
that kind of means these kind of a bit
of a psychopath as well
these psychopathic tendencies right
maybe I can get advice from the nurse
about this whole situation can't believe
I'm going to the nurse for advice but
take what you can get all right nurse
nurse nurse I got a problem I get a big
old problem please Oh me can't believe
no one in Mobius kidman have anything to
say about all this like and they see it
super weird
why can't they see anything are they
still locked out even after all this
stuff I need five more parts to get
ultimate pistol damage oh good
Castellanos that's big good to see you
it's Castellanos that's Castellanos this
place I'm going through it's hell
literally so much suffering and death
uh-huh yes you need strength to traverse
it yep strength and willpower yeah I
don't know how much more this I can take
yep you've only just begun
to test your limits to plumb the depth
of why you're really here why I'm really
here
I'm here to save Lily yes but to succeed
at that there are other challenges
you've yet to conquer whoo like shooting
gallery challenges is there more to
shoot cuz I really like to do that um
you like evac what Oh shock bolts damn
it that's not what I was hoping for but
you know it's not bad okay all right
okay
there's nothing wrong with being
cautious Oh God fighting forever you
gotta ride my ass about that all day
long okay combat skills alright whatever
maybe I should get more life no I'm
gonna get more grin and bear it
I'm gonna get more grit oh now I can
really really grin and bear it
ooh I could really get it okay recovery
maybe over this now healing items I
guess it's useful have been using a lot
more of those lately you know what why
not Blanc okay cool
combat combat combat not a combat
specialist got small arms training
that's about it okay whatever get out I
just need five more weapon parts and
then I got that next pistol upgrade okay
let's get out of here actually to see if
I can craft more stuff that I need well
since I'm going for handgun might as
well make some more of this not all of
it but a lot okay cool cool cool cool
cool let's get out of here let's say
first now ass get out here let's go
let's go let's go gotta upgrade the
melee damage no get out of here
those are herbaceous herbs sweet hope
these weren't sacred or nothing ah oh
boy REE food this is my kind of church
yeah yeah more herbaceous herbs sweet I
needed to spice up my soup Oh lovely
what kind of oh yes all right here we go
up the ladder it's the only way to go
ray
anything at the top of it okay no yeah
so so okay so everybody think about this
for a second we've been running through
this and we've been super super like
involved in just having fun and stuff
but this took such a weird turn that I
haven't seen anything about how did
Mobius not know about this this whole
like Church it's like some underworld
because if you think about it wait the
the original like the original reason
that people were recruited into this
Union City is because they were people
that were being brought in for a
religious purpose like there was the
screening was like the front of it was
like that it was a religious thing right
so there's something to that turn come
on turn harder but there's something to
that so people people like wanted it's
an outlet for fervent religious belief
that's what made them so such a good
candidate for what's going on here right
what oh oh I see okay
weird huh okay well the last one can be
manipulated all by okay all right I'll
get that later
all right so that does that nope wait no
yeah
yepper doodle sure about this
almost right no that's Oh No
that almost looks right what's wrong
there okay so
ah it's upside-down okay I get it I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it
does this only control this one by
itself was this control yeah okay this
is easy this is easy the switch this is
upside down and then the bottom one is
upside down and then I go turn the drum
but think about yeah so today did they
like they're all like fervent belief
because they wanted it so badly some of
them created like this underground
society that's weird
no I just gotta get the last one I'll
say down but yeah when you think about
it it's just weird I mean not the
weirdest thing in the world but just
bizarre to think about
all right there we go solve your puzzle
oh yeah I'm a genius
oh you know I I don't know what I
expected
yeah I don't know what I expected but uh
yep that is a thing that that is there
who do love your blood fountain really
good really good really good really good
really good it's probably not ruvik I'm
pretty sure I squish rubik's brain maybe
it's a Joe Joe you think it's Joe Joe
where's Jojo I miss Jojo I miss real
Bigley I've got a big li missing for
Jojo a big hole in my heart that's
shaped the size of Jojo hmm no good the
blood is still flowing lovely I guess
that was uh it was a pretty good pond
there for blood yep that is oh that
that's delightful excuse me gonna trip
on that bit
Oh lovely lovely lovely this is all in
their brains all in Lily's poor brain
but again I don't think that's Lilly I
don't think that's what it's all about I
think there's something more
there's gotta be it doesn't make any
sense Lilly shouldn't be that age
anymore because Sebastian has aged so
much yeah I don't think there's Rubik in
this one
that's concerning Sebastian Castellanos
Lanos you got some wannabe come yes I've
been waiting for you okay
who the hell are you Ariel my followers
called me father Theodore what do I call
you [ __ ] I hope that you will call
me that too Fred
another lunatic with a god complex huh I
already killed one of you today of
course you did
that is how you deal with every
challenge in your life through brute
force and intimidation tends to work out
and look where it has met you
uh-huh into a hell lower your weapon
use your mind instead of your visits for
once you gonna teach me some Jedi skills
we have the same goal Sebastian we can
help each other you will be reunited
with your dog and I will have the power
of the core I already know who has Lily
yes and Mayra won't give her up so
easily what where are they
I wish that I could tell you but you are
not ready you must be folded into my
flock before I can share that knowledge
I said tell me where she is accept my
invitation I can lead you away from your
own darkness
I can lead you to live things to follow
much pain the events of the past onto
every moment I showed you the path here
you must learn that I am here to help
okay sure
yeah it's the firemen with it is the
fireman to convince me soon
Oh natural natural role not as
adversaries but as allies
and for now
thanks for putting the fire out
oh wait look who finally woke up about
time were you I could use a little help
here you know how to use the gun right
you oh please tell me you have those
please tell me have another one of those
please tell me you you you you take a
big long suit break and leave me with
that keep shooting until they're dead or
we run out of ammo
okay wait can I sneak out and shoot them
up oh but my soups pew I have an upgrade
my final the final specialized good one
yeah thank you
well I want to stomp you hold my soup
skills are going for oh hello get in
here risky all right
who's there peekaboo all right no need
to be rude your gun is not powerful
ladies just want to say that right well
all right that's not good the grime
wailed out of her she's just some girl
oh hey come on come on what's going on
here give me a hand please
just breathe oh hello lamp oh oh
Oh get out the fire woman I'm not
calling her woman because I'm being
insulting that's literally her name
right now it's woman she woman take an
herb chew on an urn
once I'm sorry gang up on you yeah don't
let him gang up on you that's a strategy
oh hello no have you you seem down
Limited whoa a woman's gonna die
well okay whose fault is that all right
you know what
okay why are they all sprinting for well
she's gone down a good time here I
shouldn't be shooting it now so funny to
me either lady I know we're all on the
verge of death just because I wasn't
taking this seriously at first okay Oh
kill me kill me real quick my ankles
there we go I'm gonna Brinn and bare
this one I mean I wanted to restart that
because I was not I was not I was not I
was not taking this seriously hi
okay all right
whoa the hell how'd you get in here hey
Thank You mr. pence who sees the body
there we go all right too many times to
count that's what I meant to say I'm
gonna save that barrel for the demo dogs
all right when this is all over
yeah cuz that's the most important thing
here in this situation well we're in see
you oh damn it damn stump moving stop
stop oh boy
there we go man I wish I was a good shot
okay but what about the front can you
take care of that with your automatic
machine gun you need to update your
weapons with a nurse lady not you Jewish
hey no woman one man please
okay one of these days I'll actually hit
people hey yah whoa that was nice
hey yeah okay we go
now get this bottles everywhere yes they
are
blam how did you let that one in okay
can you shoot please can you just shoot
shooting is the best strategy against
these things I've found whoa oh that's
the opposite of it okay this one takes a
little nap ow no not today
oh come on
okay well that was I was just I was poor
handling skills that was bad okay I
started off great ended back all right I
got this one
everybody hold on your socks not so bad
yourself more compliments compliment
compliment god she's got a frickin
machine gun and I I have a pistol I'm
doing better too many times to count
all right this time I got it grab some
supplies what you can already got him
here more coming I got him lady I got
I'm getting some answers when this is
all over
he's this one I don't have to worry
about Tambo
it's basically I mean it's pretty much a
shooting gallery but
how's that one still alive okay whoa
are they
I'm literally the horse so will we wait
wait whoa whoa what what's it say
Sebastian don't let them get up on you
but
they seem tougher than they've been in
the past
okay back to shotgun okay here she comes
gonna be a prize she's just like that
why are you so tough stomp okay she did
I don't like that I don't like that Oh
Oh God hey what the hell is that noise
it's a demo go go watch out there they
need to die is all the matters oh god
here comes another one okay I'm gonna do
something that I'm gonna regret
Oh God okay I'm know oh god I changed
the button for it oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh that takes too much
time to heal oh geez pretty Barry I'm so
strong
I got a pan do I got a panders at a
crossbow oh gee I don't like you I don't
like you I don't like you
Oh shotgun shells there we go why and
how
stop stop stop stop I said stop stop
stop I can only grin and bear so much I
can't God
well shot one miss the other I got one
down goddamnit that's tough
there's legitimately tough yeah I
couldn't get her up because it would
take like ten seconds like pub G rules a
year okay what I need to do is lightly I
like one need to be careful there we go
we're just like snakes tableaux that's
all I ever won by yourself yeah there we
go that's how you Sookie it's once or
twice my melee dam is like you guys said
me told me to we've been great in this
situation no kidding really is that our
why are they not dying come on come on
oh boy
bottle your bullets do nothing
why don't you aim for the head take your
own damn advice no not that this I'm
just trying to conserve ammo is all I'm
trying to do at this juncture
super-smooth why you you taik to me I
want to try to get her up while this
one's being all stupid
now come on you [ __ ]
stop Finn oh oh my god you kill no not
to keep thinking that's the heal button
why did I change that why
I've got so many of these
yeah okay that's not good that's the
opposite of good oh can you shoot please
could you shoot shooting would be lovely
no no that's not good no no no no no
stop that now stop that stop it okay
thank you if they if they can just do
that and then I can stab them okay
that's good oh I don't have any more
bottles left you just sways you from
your actions
how am I not this person whoa qe boy I
wish we had that barrel that would have
been nice to have hey what the hell is
that noise yeah watch out don't don't
trigger those
[Music]
there we go okay
you dead now well not now's not the time
for soup collection that it I almost had
him last time I oh I was like cool I was
one demagogue away last time okay
alright yeah we gotta keep stop you oh
you're not even Sami you got a normal
face yeah perfectly normal face except
for your eyes okay let me collect
everything woman again not an insult
that's literally your name right now so
that's all I can call you eight so
impatient
take another oh I wish there was some
coffee here you know you know this place
would be really lovely if you just had
some coffee some sort you'll be
wonderful
hello thanks I don't know if I could
have done that on my own
no you couldn't have for us I'm
Sebastian I know did you it looks like
we got him for now we should make a move
before more show up mm-hmm how did I
wind up here and who are you no time for
20 questions my safe house isn't too far
we can talk on the way there
okay thank you Torres I'm glad I have
something to call you now I'll be out
here take whatever you need I just did
there might be more of those things at
least tell me how you know my name
Kidman told me to keep an eye out for
you Kidman she said she would try to get
your help if the plan went to [ __ ] and
here you are so wait I'm lost
what plan getting Lilly out of here and
then taking Mobius down for good mmm
what is it
boxes is it a box was it this box I got
the box I got the scary box don't worry
about it let me guess the way back to
your safe house uh-huh
there might be another way come on yeah
yeah I know she just told her me her
name we're names Torres your plan
Kidman didn't say anything about that
yeah well I'm sure she wasn't able to
debrief you on that in front of
everybody over here okay
all right what about it I've got it I've
got a knife I've got a soup deliver why
why is that a thing there's a perfect
you there's a gouges why couldn't you
you could climb over there was a gap
Thanks oh ah teamwork okay all right
she's so strong come on my dad old she's
so strong
so you're telling me Kidman had a plan
to take out Mobius all this time
actually it was your wife's plan wait
Myra mmm that's why she's here she's a
part of Mobius this is ridiculous
you're gonna have to duck don't blow
your back out this isn't the time Tory
should be proud of your wife she's
compelling she recruited me for this
plant it's very goopy right now why
would she join them she found out they
had Lily I knew the only way to take
them down was from the inside so she
joined up and waited for the right
moment all these years that's where she
was damn it hmm
this is a lot to take in I'm sure it is
but let's not lose focus okay all right
are you gonna just leap like the Hulk
straight up in a 10-foot vertical
yeah of course ready you step on my bad
hand there you go
well did Taurus don't need your help
Sebastian Taurus guy all on her own
Tori's can't shoot but Torres can climb
in and lift things Hey that's what toys
can do you're just gonna forget about me
okay
it seemed like that's exactly what
you're gonna do Oh strong charge you're
so strong ah you're mashing the e button
I can tell the plan TM all caps she's so
strong oh she's so strong the plan right
who else was involved in this little
mutiny just four of us me Kidman Myra
and Theodore Theodore father Theodore
father Theodore I just call him Theodore
Wallace you know him
we've met but he doesn't want to save
Lily he wants her for himself tried to
talk me into hunting down Myra - he's
the one who screwed everything up how
was this whole thing supposed to go once
my run theater got Lilly Theodore and I
were gonna get her out while Myra stayed
behind to take care of Mobius Kidman
stayed outside and make sure we got out
of stem safely [ __ ] he was supposed to
be easy
nothing's ever easy
mmm the plan featuring soup Oh was a
thing
uh-oh who's your safe house blow up did
you put a lot of explosives in your safe
house Oh looks like your safe house blew
up okay I'm looking I'm looking real
hard with my eyes I'm looking so good
you need me a sneak look no wait no I
follow me follow me I'm following you
now
all right fine then is there a map or
something whoa Daria's okay all right
okay all right Oh whoo ow my back all
right yeah all right I'm not controlling
this huh Ranger oh really zooming in
with my eyeballs my peepers
Jenna
that's
little leaf blower was that like the
friendly neighborhood gardener before
this happened no one went down here Oh
guys wish for your safe house I wouldn't
put my safe house in the open like that
hidden we've got to get past those
things to get there that red banner
behind that building yeah
the hatch to my safe house is under it
okay I'll take the lead stay low and
keep behind me stay low
I've seen these things before don't get
near them while they're on fire no why
what that seemed like the best option
all right time for all my sneaking
skills to come into play hey follow me
lady we got this we got this together
all right cool okay okay that well hello
hello friend hello friend don't worry
about me worry about me hey come on now
wait let's all be friends here okay well
that's
Oh right give me a hug don't give me a
buzz then go exactly as I suspected it
would
[Laughter]
just that he did like oh I hope you hope
you learned your lesson oh [ __ ] oh jeez
okay all right come with me your safe
house
Oh yada yada yada yeah p.m. I'm not even
gonna go get that herb because that's
what got it oh okay I'll take the lead
stay low and keep behind me stay low
keeping the bushes deep to the bushes
it's fire-demons gem oh ah a bush gotta
go for the bushes I please or as or
Torres or as now is the time with which
to hide Torres Jim Torres please please
oh you know what I'm gonna go for it
this was a mistake going for it at this
fun good thing I got a bush they'll
never suspect the bush okay that's a
problem Torres oh good thing I'm in a
bush
dabbe hey whoa hey who you're doing with
that go for you you can't sprint on you
but I can stab on you ha ha your mistake
your mistake not being on fire oh that's
much easier than I thought it'd be ok
well Torres is out in the open Torres
great cover you're really doing me proud
you're doing me a real proud did you
know that you knew like a probably go
for that one but you know me up see that
would have been a mistake by sprinting
towards that and would have caught right
on fire now that wouldn't help to
anybody you know I'm gonna go for it
hello kidney left because I stabbed
something alright okay wait yeah you
didn't see nothin right I don't know
this is something about him some by the
way they move did I get the GUP friend
I'm gonna go get the group from this
this friend here was this needle of
Jesus this is the best thing it's the
best thing I love this I love this game
so much [ __ ] this game so much oh that's
the greatest game okay I'll leave that
one alone he'll come back in me later I
just missed him can't believe
who more goop oh yeah I forgot I took
down a goop monster right here all right
right there yes please and write your
yes please one whose ass this was why
they felt the need to burn it alive whoa
that's oh didn't notice you there don't
mind Torres or is just a big dumb dummy
or as likes it great cover Torres they
don't suspect a thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
those are me leave them for fight for
another day's another fight day okay
alright you you got it Torres you got it
I'm gonna go back and take care of this
guy apparently that's what I'm gonna do
with my spiritual God okay well this is
the ninth I beat a bush ah they'll never
destruction
he's charging somebody stop him please
honey
the best the best thing I've ever seen
in my life and bar none
my favorite part about this game Torres
is gonna die it's nothing I can do about
it oh geez Tours is down oops
oh okay you know I'm gonna go for it Oh
Jordan
it's uh good luck take blockers
you got it oh boy
never suspect I'm in a bush you've lost
me Oh George got backup Oh perfect
Hey guards guards get over doors doors
doors dirt no oh oh oh we got a tree
maybe ah there's a bush behind this tree
never suspect me behind this bush Doris
Doris you got something on you got some
oh sorry
tried to warn you sorry nothing I can do
there's nothing I can do Doris nothing I
can do absolutely nothing
I am so he's on fire I can't let him
near my bush
okay
yeah Wow let's just in my book doors
your gun doesn't do [ __ ] shoot please oh
here he comes
scary scary scary very scary very scary
I knew Torrez could handle it I knew it
I knew towards good handling from the
very beginning door is he okay you're
all right Torres please korres doors
were here
torres we're here how do we get in cars
we're here look it's the bandana Torres
please
Hey look the Sky box Torres Torres
Torres please oh oh that's what you're
looking at okay you got it you got this
you got my Bush sorry got hide behind
got it okay maybe not all right but I
don't think he knows I'm here
I'm gonna Bush very clearly secret Bush
yeah that's right slink off that's right
you don't know nothing oh I'll get him
don't worry don't worry Torres I'll get
revenge for you he cuts stop spin on
fire there we go nice print please I
can't come on I know you got it in you
Joe Joe all over again except this is
toe toe toe toe please toto
you can do it dodo dodo you want to go
for more toe toe toe toe don't oh don't
get up don't get art boom three I'd be
real devastated if that went tore were
to arise toe toe toe toe yo dodo dodo
dodo what are you looking at Toto go to
see something in the bushes toto
alright come on let's go get him don't
barely we got to go get him are they
still coming they still coming for us
bush
this was my favorite thing it was oh wow
okay all right I see what I see what's
transpiring here how about a smoke bomb
will that put you out oh who did thought
what what now they'll never know what
soup dumb in the fight so so so that's
how you do it dodo you get you
understand it now dodo all right cool
all right Doh doh-doh doh-doh doh-doh
but you'll do you'll do you'll do okay
you'll do I think we I think I think
Toto's transfixed see big toto
shell-shocked by just how many times
I've left her to die
stab them now just where I can stab them
my stab them please them apparently I
can't stab them you've decided that now
[Laughter]
no no please all right dodo I'm here doc
let's talk happy puppy okay anyway well
I guess there's no getting back out of
that one there's no place like home runs
a close second I got in here cookie
dough at least until iCarly ah so you do
have a lot of explosives in your safe
house I don't know why I I assumed that
before but now it just seems logical oh
jeez is the best that is the best I love
this game toto
can i okay thank you toto oh jeez
so what are we gonna do about Theodore I
don't know super he's insane his hideout
looks like an inquisitors Dream Home I
should be relieved that Myra has Lilly
instead of him but what Myra has Lilly
yeah but I'm not sure that's good news
she's changed
this place seems to have affected her
she's hiding trying to protect Lily from
Theodore and he'll tear this place apart
to find them if I can stop him maybe
Myra will come to her senses and we can
get Lily out of here
maybe baby needs to take out Theodore
yeah but I have to find him first
how are you gonna do that onio help me
before I'll call him but I better give
Cuban an update first right but be
careful what you say over that thing
she's probably in the control room with
that lizard hovering over her hmm
Sebastian where have you been thanks
tomorrow yeah I did more than that I
eliminated him good and she slipped
through my fingers again I already hear
that the good news is that I've been in
contact with agent Torres her Intel has
been invaluable the bad news is there's
someone more powerful than Stephano who
wants to take this place over mm-hmm he
needs Lily to do that Torres told me you
know him too
he's a real smooth talker I know I trust
you kid the whole fee coffee right there
coffee time to get down to business time
to get down to business
O'Neill it's Sebastian come in huh
something's wrong I got to try and find
him hmm you should stay here and get
your explosives and weapons ready I'll
need your help once I locate Theodore is
there a way into the marrow from here
yeah there's a Mobius computer in that
room it'll take you exit 72 great I'll
call you when I'm ready hang tough
Torres got it
good luck Sebastian okay thank you all
right let me get me a sweet sip of that
bill listen that's not what I was going
for it but I'll take it you know maybe
that first there we go what's in this
case then a cup of coffee hmm these two
oh it's a smoke bomb no it's a frost
bomb even better for soup
ah nice ice-cold soup mmm perfect
perfect perfect in every way who was
that over there yeah
this is tourism journal I'm just gonna
read this okay all right journal is
written in neat feminine hand the most
why is that a necessary detail all right
not sure how long I've been waiting for
Meyer and Theodor to return time is
sketchy concept inside stem even more so
since Lily escaped all I know is that
they should have returned by now if I
die near I just want whoever defines
this diary to know that I went in
willingly I did something a long long
time ago something that I regret that's
why I'm here waiting to take Lily out of
here this is my chance at redemption
then maybe a shot is starting my life
over either way I'm committed to this
plan I'll see it through to the end no
matter what but it's obvious something
went wrong if that's the case I should
keep an eye out for help like kidman
told me to but this place is falling
apart around me hope I can find him if
it gets sent inside there we go okay
well got that all right now time for
sweet sweet cup of coffee yeah what does
that mean Oh feminine hand okay maybe
maybe the idea was that was supposed to
be a clue before you actually meted toto
but I don't know about that mm-hmm
that really plugs all those burn wounds
nothing like a hot cup of coffee to
remind me that I hugged a flaming zombie
there all right anyway that is all the
time that I have for this episode here
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will be back tomorrow at 8 a.m. again
I will actually be at 8 a.m. I won't be
50 minutes late like I was today but
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye guys bye see ya bye